collet majesté agence écologique et
kliment qui s'est aujourd'hui et c'est
mal mais tout cela n'a que commencer et
cela va empirer 420 gigatonnes
d'émissions de co2 c'est ce qu'il nous
restait au 1er janvier 2008 pour avoir
67 % de chances de rester au dessous des
1,5 degrés d'augmentation de la
température au niveau mondial et nous
savons que ce chiffre est désormais
passé à 360 gigatonnes au niveau des
missions actuelles ce budget démission
aura totalement disparu d'ici huit ans
et demi et depuis que j'ai commencé
avons parlé d'ailleurs le monde vient
d'émettre traite de 800 mille tonnes de
co2 et s'il reste des personnes qui se
trouvent des excuses pour ne pas écouter
pour ne pas lâcher
je voudrais vous reposez la même
question est-ce qu'il existerait un
autre via sip est ce qu il existerait un
accord de paris secret que nous ne
connaîtrions pas un accord de paris qui
nature est pas l'aspect de l'équipe
inquiète
auriez vous un budget différent qui nous
permettent de rester au dessous de
l'augmentation de 1,5 degré sans pipe en
obtient 100 personnes ont choisi de ne
pas venir à cette réunion aujourd'hui
certaines personnes ont choisi de ne pas
nous écouter
ce n'est pas grave après tout nous ne
sommes jamais que des enfants n'avaient
pas le devoir de kilos gain de les
écouter
par contre vous avez le devoir d'écouter
aux scientifiques
tout ce que nous faisons
knight munissez-vous derrière les
scientifiques
[Applaudissements]